sono contento e anche un po spaventato
nel presentarvi il mio papà io mi
drogavo e piangevo perché dentro ci
avevo una sofferenza che faceva paura ma
io con michele ci ho già parlato qualche
anno fa telepaticamente e cosa ci siamo
detti ha perso in una giornata e mezzo
11 milioni veramente persone di chiesa
anche sì sì sì amo ha troppo no è un
pezzo della luna
capitolo ah scusate ma faccio una cosa
così grave nella sua vita è stato rapito
due volte dagli alieni erano alte più di
due metri due metri qualche cosa oddio
già ti amo non piacerà a tutti non
piaceva tutto gesù cristo figurati noi
siamo 0 oggi
[Applauso]
[Musica]